hello everyone we have another exciting
game here from round 12 of the 2018 Tata
Steel chess tournament but before I show
you the game I would just like to show
you the current standings before the
final round these are the standings as
you can see Geary and Carlson are tied
in first place with eight and a half
points followed by Mama dro in third
place with 8 points and Kramnik and
Anand are in fourth and fifth place with
seven and a half points so there's still
one more round to go and it's just
anything can happen on an off chance
maybe both Geary and Carson will lose
their games tomorrow so if that happens
even even ok maama Dro can't win his
game and if that happens even on and
Kramnik have a chance of getting first
place here in the tata steel chess
tournament but as you can see both
current cousin had a almost perfect
tournament not a single game lost Sergey
Kerrigan here in sixth place with seven
points is also the third player who
hasn't lost a single game so it will be
a very exciting last round tomorrow like
I said anything can happen
Geary is facing wayy and the Carlson is
facing his old nemesis Sergey Kerrigan
who like I said hasn't lost a single
game like Carlsen in this tournament so
that definitely anything can happen okay
that being said let's see this exciting
game
we have onigiri with the white pieces
facing bhaskar and audubon and someone
in the comments told me it's a Baskaran
but as I have really no way of knowing I
will just call him a debunk
so c4 by giving the English defense and
this is one thing I always enjoy about
Adam and he's a very exciting player and
always has some nice opening in store
for his opponent here he plays the
immediate the g6 the so-called the great
snake variation we have d4 Bishop to g7
and Knight to f3 c 5b v by giri and d6
d4 and ecig so very similar to the
Benoni only this night still hasn't been
developed to f6 or e7 we have Bishop to
d3
each after Sun d5 seek after Sun d5 and
Bishop to g4 by Audubon might be to the
Knight to f6 we have castles castles h3
and Bishop captures on f3 Knight
captures and here we have the classic
Benoni upon Bush c4 the idea is you
wanna you want to give up your C pond
for this very nice central epon so
Bishop captures Knight captures and now
rook to e1 attacking the knight rook to
e8 defending and Queen to c2 adding more
pressure to the knight on e4 here Knight
to f6 moving the attack piece rook at
first Knight captures and here we have
Bishop to g5 attacking the Queen tonight
back to f6 and now comes Knight to d4
here Audubon goes for Queen to b6
attacking the knight on d4 and Geary
plays Bishop back to e3 now with some
ideas of some discovered attacks to the
Queen from the bishop on e3 and here are
the bongos for Knight to g4 and what's
the idea well it's pretty obvious now
there's a double attack on the night
here on d4 and basically any discovery
you make the night things simply capture
Bishop and the Queen will no longer be
attacked so any discovery made will most
likely lose the game but here Gary finds
the absolute best move he plays Queen to
e4 this adds more pressure to this
attack knight on g4 and also it defends
this knight on d4 so what do you do here
you could consider Knight captures on d3
getting rid of this strong bishop if you
play this Knight captures you get Queen
to e8 check and after Bishop blocks you
play F characters on e3 and what are you
gonna do here how do you develop the
pieces probably if you want to get again
any activity here with the black pieces
you have to play something like Knight
to c6 and after Queen captures you've
got to run before
pawn captures and now Queen captures
with check you win the bishop on c4 and
after queen capture some b7 both players
have 5 points but Gary would be up the
exchange and I mean it's a it's a
winning game for white soul not no point
in doing this so not capturing the
bishop on e3 rather
adhi bongos 492 f6 we have Queen to e7
and this is a very important move not
allowing not allowing the Queen and in a
queen to c7 Queen to d8 as if the screen
would ever come to d8 would check it
then again she would she would block the
knight and the rook from ever being
developed so you can't play something
like Queen to a5 if you play Queen to a5
you lose the beat seven-point lose the
rook so you have the option of maybe
going night to a6 or Knight to d7 so
Knight to d7 is played by a demon and
now comes Knight to b5 you had to play
something now finally there is a
discovered attack from the bishop to the
Queen and here you don't have the option
of maybe playing Queen to d8 and then
after Queens are exchanged Gary will
snatch that pawn on a seven but Audubon
decides to go for Bishop to f8
immediately attack the Queen so Gary
captures Queen on b6 Bishop captures on
e7 and now Bishop captures on a seven
and at the end of this very nice
skirmish Murie wanna pawn now is that
enough to win the game it's fur geared
to prove Knight to e5 attacking the
bishop and we have b3 Knight captures
big captures and rook to c8 now
attacking that backward c4 pawn rook to
e1 first attacking the bishop on e7
bishop moves and now Bishop to d4
attacking the knight on f6 Knight to d7
and here rook to see one now defending
the c4 pawn rook to a8 rook to c2
defending the a to pawn rook to a6 and
here give replays rook to e2 and I saw a
glimpse of this in the live coverage
they thought the giri was actually
bluffing that he wanted to go rook to e8
and that this wasn't actually that good
of a move and Ali once seemed to think
so as well as he played rock to a4 going
for this e4 pawn and a giri gives it up
he plays rook to e8 here we have rook
captures on c4 and now comes a rock to
d8 and it's a very delicate position
you're 927 is attack
the night is also protecting preventing
this bishop from coming to f6 as white
definitely wants to go to have six and
verse 27 to win the bishop on it on f8
or maybe maybe go Bishop to f6 the g5
and then to h6 so what do you do here if
you try something like row before so if
rook captures night then this rook
captures this Knight simply a four and
again you have to do something about
this night so other one immediately goes
Knight to e5 not allowing the bishop any
Bishop to f6 ad has the button here it
pushes f4 we have Knights to d3 and now
comes the ship to have sex with the
terrible threat of Bishop to e7 Audubon
stops this rook to e4 and now comes
Knight captures on d6
grabbing another pawn the bishop of
course is pinned it can't capture the
night we have rook to e1 check King to
h2 and now comes Knight to f2 and here
Bishop to g5 the threat is Bishop to h6
with the checkmate and an interesting
idea is because a diamond played h5 here
why not came to g7 stopping Bishop to h6
well because King to g7 actually loses
the game you get night to e8 check you
have to move King J now you get Knight
f6 check King has to move again and now
you get d6 and this d6 pawn is now some
becoming a queen you can't capture it if
you capture it and group to g8 this is
checkmate
so after this is probably F after this
d6 move you'd probably have to do
something like h6 let's say a bishop h4
and now rook to d1
you can't grab the night because black
would capture here so probably d7 and
after any move you make you get rook to
e8 and there is no stopping this pawn
from becoming a queen so after this
Bishop to g5 move Adam and decided to go
for h5 simply preventing checkmate [ __ ]
ph8 was played and here h4 we have g4
now
King to h7 and now Bishop rook captures
it's interesting the giri doesn't
capture with the bishop he captures with
the rook and allows this king to capture
the bishop and this is very interesting
what happens if you capture the bishop
is if king characters on h6 then you get
rook captures on f7 and there is a very
little you can do here well you probably
you have to give up peace probably with
Knight captures if you play any other
move you simply get g5 check King h5 on
the move and rook to h7 checkmate
so after this rook to f8 move Audubon
doesn't capture the bishop he was 93 and
we have rook captures on f7 and Gary's
trying to force a demand to grab the
bishop body ban of course the clients
rope to the faith check we have team to
h7 and here we have night to f7 and I
believe before this night 37 after rook
to f8 check it was in this position that
Adi one resigned the game why did he
resign because after King to h7 you get
knife to f7 and there is really nothing
you can do here there is of course a
very terrible threat of rope to h8
checkmate there's really no way for you
to stop this if equals g5 to maybe make
room for King on g6 you get f5 but I
mean still you're down a piece and
you're getting checkmated and there is
even and an interesting variation where
black can't avoid checkmate its rook to
e2 check King moves rook e1 check King
g2 and now Knight to a4 check and now if
you go to F 2 you get Knight 2 D 3 check
back so you have to go King F 3 and now
Knight to g6 preventing this checkmate
but now you simply get Knight capture
son g5 check King characters and now you
get rope to f6 now again you lose the
piece you will be down a piece and down
three points and your white is
completely winning here and of course if
you capture the night which you
definitely don't want to do here then
you get CalPERS and g6 checkmate so even
with the best defense there is nothing
nothing black can do here so like I said
after this rope to f8 check Ottoman
resigned
game and like I said here you have if
you forgot giri and cousin are tied in
first place tomorrow we'll see who will
be the winner of the 2018 Tata Steel
chess tournament if you haven't watched
if there will be a tie there will be a
tie-break played the tiebreak will be
played to blitz games five minutes plus
three seconds increment and I've seen an
interview with chronic chronic said that
he wasn't very pleased with this because
you're here playing this huge tournament
you're suffering for two weeks and then
and then first place will be decided
what a blitz game so some players enjoy
this some players don't it's but it's
the way it is so that's the game I do
hope you enjoyed it as usual you can
check two of my previous videos here
thank you all for watching and I will
see you soon probably with the winner of
the tata steel chess tournament